did you know that you can turn plastic  waste into school bags  [Music]  in Nigeria waste management is a huge  challenge  every year the country turns out more  than 30 million tons of trash less than  a third of that is connected so trash is  literally everywhere social entrepreneur  Tony joy is trying to make a difference  she founded an initiative that creates  wealth from waste the team collects  trash and uses it as a resource turning  plastic waste into school bags  decoration and even jewelry  these pet bottles are being used to  build a house  the initiative also trains young people  and the value of waste creating new  sources of income and help it the  environment do you like that if you are  also doing your bit tell us about it  visit our website or send us a tweet  hashtag doing your bit we share your  stories